[Music]
next level FaceTime news oh gosh ooh I
hate FaceTime me too I'll tell you why
later submitted by David's Honda Element
thank you that mighty car King welcome
to shitty car key Honda Element
it's just on two elements [ __ ] y'all to
the jingle oh yeah the music I saw the
visuals of all the Honda elements like
1990 Saturn's human uber lets users
attend events using another person's
body what what does that mean what in
the world is going that means you could
read somebody to go to an event that you
need to go to exactly like a piggyback
ride all the way to the event you rent
this person and you could tell them to
wear whatever you want and then they put
this like helmet thing on yeah and then
they interact with the party
what were you why do they gotta have
that help no wait no is it like FaceTime
where they could talk so they're talking
into this thing but the body is there
but the face is still you yeah talking
yeah oh I think that is awesome
that's so weird and I want to be that
job cuz that's like anonymous and then
like your view I feel like you will
always want to play that before in like
the testimonials it like before and
after or like the infomercials where
they're like use it harder opens drawer
and you know they show also do like like
you know how you want to get invited to
parties but you don't actually want to
go hey Who am I never like wow that
here's all my social anxiety this would
be pretty you could be there without
being yeah you and I would do this is
what I would do so I this is perfect for
breakup moments
perfect for breakups dude have to act it
out - you don't really have to be there
you know II mean that is emotes as much
they could vote for you yeah I mean that
is a shoulder acne no there I'm so sorry
early banana and then I would just get
the motions I'm crying now like it hurts
my heart if you need to get into a fight
that's what you you try to meet me at
the park at 11 o clock I'm calling my
uber boom he's dead jackass dude what
what now you could clone yourself for
everything yeah you could go to birthday
parties like three birthday parties at
once you could go to like yeah you could
go on a second honeymoon
as that body yeah remember how we would
always say like man if they're only like
three more of me like I would get more
but you still have to be the one on the
FaceTime you don't need like three
phones if you want to do like all those
things that was yeah so they're calling
this chameleon mask and it was presented
in Singapore they're just describing it
as a human over and you know people like
if they have commitment but then they
also have to go to certain events like
for example of a parent it has to work
but then they have a kids recital they
can use this chameleon mask and still
attend it while you're handling whatever
I like to think the chameleon mask is
that the kids recital like just in the
audience is glowing screen and if and if
your dick doesn't work anymore you could
have that person [ __ ] your wife while
she thinks she's still [ __ ] you yeah
although you have to watch your wife
getting [ __ ] by another dude and like
what if she enjoys it too much you still
it's still your baby it's only your wife
but if he looks not a dick someone
else's dick exactly but you're watching
your wife's face like we're enjoying it
with
no you just have to make sure that you
come at the same time he covers your
dick doesn't work how do you come kind
of like her you commanded you have to
tell him you I don't know you're coming
right
I guess so sir this is crazy yeah all
the possibilities I love to slap
somebody what I believe what you're
working and you're like oh I gotta be at
that convention and then you switch off
and then you get a ball how you been or
if you want to fight with your spouse
and you don't really want to be there
that's sick
[ __ ] you [ __ ] but you're
selected like is that how you fight with
your spouse I don't know I just try to
make it extreme how do you fight with
bars
yeah does she say [ __ ] you [ __ ]
no cuz if it gets there let me someone's
gonna get a fist in their [ __ ] face I
feel like if you're robotic with your
emotions I really want to see what you
fight like I mean I'm still lucky
nothing okay okay it's only so much I'm
a robot robot crazy okay normal stuff
she's very emotional okay so stop was it
yeah but when it's a crazy stuff then it
doesn't really affect what the [ __ ]
wrong with you you [ __ ] five-year-old
yeah yeah mines anger too but I cry with
it but it's not because I'm sad it's
just that's how I relation of oceans
yeah I'm just so angry but then I start
crying but then I'm like but then he's
thinking I'm vulnerable yeah but I'm no
I'm just it's just like a release of
energy like I'm just so mad it's coming
out my eyeballs oh you see how [ __ ]
pissed so pissed I wish it was a
different book oppress righteously look
at this evidence I wish there was a
color-coded like green tears were not
angry and when you get angry you cry
it's just acid and hold on before oh
[ __ ] that's gangster I love that [ __ ]
dude great feels great man
you're very kinky some tears of my love
crying yeah
because it makes you feel like your
nasal passages are all clear after I
cried recently I saw I saw I saw
train the train to Pusan you cried at
the end with his daughter oh I thought a
little bit cheesy but I'm glad you
thought that [ __ ] got me dude it
blindsided me I was like what's up with
this part oh no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I couldn't cry cuz the daughter look
like a little boy I [ __ ] hate crying
sometimes
because I get surprised when I cry and I
look at other people like to fix my
problem I've only learned not like the
past maybe three four years to really
learn how to cry is you know like it's
so repressed in your family yeah some
reason like I mean cry out command nah I
can cry some what if it's like acting
situation I can't but for some reason
now like what I think of things I could
cry movies now all movies I cried in all
movies every movie every movie you know
they always started right in a
sentimental scene I always cry that was
such a good moment a heartless [ __ ] one
of the last time you watched a movie
that made you cry mmm I don't know you
gotta ask him yeah I am Sam did you try
it I am Sam I don't think I've seen
garbage that won't get me right here
maybe Mulholland was one of that's like
cinematically beautiful so it didn't
really get the lorry was touching oh my
god the train to Busan story is really
touching the guy the [ __ ] zombies
[Laughter]
he's like the real situation does make
me cry zombies however oh what's so real
about Lala let your [ __ ] out at the
park bench
no wonder you didn't cry because all you
saw was stupid dancing no train the
boost out is a real love stories about a
father and his daughter
it sounds like [ __ ] train the [ __ ] and
that's all I can think about that was
the trick
good for you you cried for [ __ ]
zombie movies alright what did the
zombie from them you're better than Geo
then God made me cry really hard
oh yeah blowers yeah Oh sad that almost
pretty sad I haven't seen that one
it's about drug dealing yeah wait at the
end yeah the daughter never you can't
see the it's you'll forget that's why
it's okay you don't even it'll blindside
you yeah you'll just be slapped across
the face and your eyes are just like dog
oh just one last job at the time I was
selling drugs at the time I was selling
drugs so that's why it really connected
with yeah yeah sometimes I just look for
something to make me cry because I feel
all this pent-up energy and I just need
to release it so I'll just like search
Vagos and make me cry and I'll just like
you know what me sound like a crazy lady
[ __ ] when I see people do extraordinary
things it like moves me like crazy yeah
like a kung fu master that get his balls
kicked all the time with movies and TV
shows just like anything I hate having
that not oh that's what that's what you
got a look let out I can't that's what I
like when I know that not is what I need
to cry cuz it adjusts all it comes out
and I'm like well I can breathe in my
lungs again you know what else makes me
cry
[ __ ] Malaysian Bank commercials about
a bank you [ __ ]
thirty Seconds to how do they do that
cinematic I'm sure they know how to make
short films yeah [ __ ] it what else makes
me cry though taxes holy [ __ ] that's a
bad kind of cry though
that's not a therapeutic cry I'm like oh
they're so [ __ ] up
there's taking all our money we're on
the where's it going not the road yours
are those the green ones or the blue
ones never forget ice hot red that's
[ __ ] confusing it [ __ ] that [ __ ]
would win you I literally saw I saw two
tears that were red and blue intertwine
and they come down no I as soon as she
says I said we was blue and she said
honey mediately turn around picture my
tears that's like you know how the flame
gets so so so hot and white that's
that's exactly the feel that you try
taxes so it's just another thing color
white and clear yeah when you're saying
flame tons white your meaning it's clear
meaning it's white oh just let her have
her [ __ ] I want to know Berryman's to
fight Oh
during this argument the point is she
did not cry and train to Pusan that's
what I'm trying to say you should watch
it I should watch this I probably I
cried in every movie you didn't cry in
it that's good you were watching it with
this girl Indiana Jones probably
probably dude How to Train Your Dragon
now I've seen it in pieces but I have
taiko so it's always like why should I
only watch the first one he sounds like
a cat you use a little cute cat that's
what they sound like
that's cute apples mouth is always open
the fool is always surprised constantly
I like yeah he's so cute and then it
turns into a smile yeah I thought it's
so funny when I with Leia right Lansbury
doing it because she's a girl yeah I
mean she wishes he'll allow I was a dude
yeah he's a dude
what your girl would look like if you
guys had a car that's a good question I
don't know I hope it looks more like
over here me too
[Music]